calciné ravagé par les flammes plus de
quatre hectares de végétation partis en
fumée dans cette forêt de lusigny sur
ouche d'immenses parcelles brûlé toute
la journée les pompiers vont se relayer
pour étouffer les derniers foyers
soulever les pierres et arroser la
braise pour empêcher que le feu reprenne
sur ce terrain accidenté
la difficulté est les deux d'établir des
tuyaux donc au fur et à mesure que l'on
avance donc sur un terrain escarpé un
terrain plein d'embûches en fait de sous
bois de pierre le tronc d'arbre c'est
typiquement le feu de forêt que l'on
peut rencontrer notamment dans le sud de
la france mais on voit maintenant que
ici dans les régions qui sont pas
vraiment conforté à ce type de feront
bien à ce type d'intervention des feu
maîtrisé mais avec des épisodes de
sécheresse de plus en plus fréquents les
autorités s'inquiètent pour l'avenir
si on continue à avoir des sécheresses à
répétition comme on a depuis deux ans
évidemment on ne peut être qu'inquiet ça
peut être comme dans le sud c'est à dire
avoir régulièrement des incendies qui se
propagent en attendant à lusigny sur
ouche
il va falloir faire un diagnostic pour
voir s'il est possible d'exploiter les
bois brûlé ou s'il faut déjà repenser à
des plantations